the president's been taking the heat
from fellow democrats who insist he's
not doing enough to combat climate
change and they were disappointed with
no announcement of a climate emergency
or executive action only a repetition of
the threat that he'll take action if
congress doesn't this is an emergency an
emergency and i will i will look at it
that way i said last week and i'll say
it again loud and clear as president
i'll use my executive powers to combat
climate the climate crisis and the
absence of congressional action
the problem in congress essentially lies
in the senate in particular one of the
president's own party joe manchin who's
pulled out of negotiations over climate
legislation given the senate's 50-50
split this means unless some republicans
break party ranks any legislation will
simply not pass because of uh you know
one senator in particular joe manchin
who gets more money from the oil and gas
industry than virtually any other
senator
biden he is blocking biden's legislation
in the senate so that biden cannot enact
his climate agenda there
the site of the president's speech was
carefully chosen
the brayton point power station was
labeled one of the filthy five
industrial polluters in the past but the
coal-fired plant was decommissioned five
years ago and is now set to become part
of a massive offshore wind power project
that could generate a significant amount
of green energy
and the president listed what he views
as his administration's successors
including the most recent
today we begin the process
to develop wind power in the gulf of
mexico as well for the first time
a real opportunity to power millions of
additional homes from wind
but this will not be enough for the
president's critics who continue to call
for stronger executive action president
biden has the power to declare a climate
emergency which could assist his
administration in limiting the
activities of fossil fuel industries on
federal lands but this in turn could
lead to the administration being
involved in long drawn-out battles in
the courts thank you
thank you the president has confirmed
his administration's message that
executive action remains on the table
but while the delay in execution
continues there's a real danger that
this could become another perceived
biden failure that voters would note at
the midterm polls
mike hanna al jazeera washington